[موسيقى]
الانجليزيه وكلها حماس للتحدث عن تجربتها
بعد ان اصبحت اول سيده في بريطانيا
والعالم تتلقى خلايا دم حمراء زرعت في
مختبر
كنت دائما اتبرع بالدم ولكنني توقفت بعد
اصابه بالسرطان اذ لم يعودوا قادرين على
استخدام دمه لكن وبعد تسع سنوات من تاكد
خلو من السرطان دعيت للمشاركه في تجربه
هذه المره تلقيت خلايا دم حمراء زرعت في
المختبر وهكذا بدات التجربه هنا في هذا
المختبر التابع لجامعه كيمبريتش تلقت
ايفون ومتطوعون اخرون خلايا دم حمراء
للمره الاولى على الاطلاق زرعت في اطار
تجربه يقوم بها قسم نقل الدم والاعضاء
التابع لخدمه الصحه الوطنيه في جامعه
بريستول البريطانيه البروفيسور
النقل الدم المشارك في التجربه اعتبرها
رائده لانها المره الاولى التي تزرع خلايا
دم حمراء باستخدام خلايا جذعيه بشريه
تمكنت من التجربه من دراسه العمر
الافتراضي للخلايا المزروعه مقارنه بخلايا
دم المتبرعين
خلايا الدم الحمراء المنقوله من متبرئين
تكون قد قضت في الجسم حوالي 120 يوما لكن
الخلايا التي تزرع في المختبر تكون حادثه
العهد لذلك فعمرها الافتراضي يكون اطول
وهذا ما تؤكده بيانات المختبر يتوقع
الباحثون ان تمهد هذه التجربه الطريقه
في خلايا الدم الحمراء المزروعه للمرضى
المصابين بامراض مثل الطلاسيميا او
الخلايا المنجليه ومن يحتاجون الى نقل دم
بشكل منتظم ومن لديهم فئات دمين يصعب
حصولهم على متبرعي
قدرتنا على صناعه الدم في المختبر ستسمح
لنا باختيار خلايا جذعيه تناسب ما يحتاج
اليه كل مريض كما ان العمليه تساعد على
تخليص المرضى الذين يتلقون دما باستمرار
من كميات الحديد السامه التي تتراكم في
الجسم وتؤثر على اعضاء مثل القلب والكبد
لكن الباحثين يقولون انه في المستقبل
القريب لن تستخدم الخلايا المزروعه الا
للمرضى ذوي الاحتياجات المعقده للغايه
لنقل الدم وان التجربه تتطلب سنوات اضافيه
قبل تعميمها في المستشفيات من حرب الجزيره
كيمبريدج